Tristan if you're watching this I want
to invite you but you know right now
he's in jail Tristan as well yeah both
of them are in jail stay strong strong
just power
unfazed
we hope that Allah frees our brother
Andrew Tate and we hope that Tristan
takes this time in jail to contemplate
upon Islam and upon the purpose of life
and we invite you to Islam and sneak off
so I want to start off with this
statement he said is very interesting
which is the point that I think I'm
going to raise right here is there are
people in the world who will punch you
in the face if you insult Jesus Christ
interview insult
um uh if you insult Jesus Christ or the
Virgin Mary or anything and those people
are
the Muslims now if you don't know
religion and you don't know religious
history very well then I guess you don't
know that one of the most profit and one
of the most important prophets in Islam
is Jesus Son of Mary as they refer to
him or Jesus Christ as Christians call
them so this Dubai the Middle East the
United Arab Emirates the Muslim world is
a part of the world where you could not
walk around and freely insult Jesus so I
feel perfectly at home in the Middle
East and I feel perfectly at home living
with my brother who is now a Muslim he's
going to put a Quran up above his title
belts in the house I have no problem
with that book being in my house I am
very happy
um for my brother in the decision he
made I think that it's going to benefit
him uh in the long run I think that he's
a lot happier than I've seen him in a
very long time and good for him
now I was asked about my own conversion
or potential conversion and and here was
my answer my answer was very simple
somebody some idiot actually here in the
Middle East
some British guy said to me oh yeah if
you convert to Islam that'd be really
beneficial to you and it would help you
out in lots of ways and I explained to
him I said that's not how conversion
Works my friend and if I were to live in
the Middle East
you know although living as a Christian
even if it was more difficult which it's
not because it's a very free open
country with freedom of religion
um I would not convert for the reason of
getting any kind of material
um or social benefit I don't think
that's how conversion works I don't even
think you choose to convert no more than
you choose to believe that the sky is
blue or that the uh the ocean's filled
with water I believe that conversion is
something that happens to you now I've
been doing a lot of reading
um a lot of people in Dubai have gifted
me some wonderful books The Miracles of
the Prophet Muhammad and so on and I I
enjoy reading this material conversion
isn't something that I plan to do
because I don't believe it's something
people plan to do I believe it's
something that naturally happens to
people and something that um you know
you don't choose because you don't
choose to change your mind you don't
choose to change your mind your mind
just naturally changes as you're
persuaded so as for a personal
conversion I will say no that's probably
not coming
um it's certainly not coming yet if it
does happen it will be an organic
process but nevertheless I you know I
believe that Christians and Muslims are
now finally United
so over the history of Christianity and
Islam there's been lots of fights
there's been lots of arguments and
there's been lots of wars and the
Crusades even the Christians went in and
tried to take Muslim land from them and
and the Ottoman Empire too invaded
Europe through Romania and got even to
the gates of Vienna there was lots of
beef between Christians and Muslims but
that was obviously due to religious uh
differences because people were very uh
they were uh let's call them zealots
back then but also it was about
political power it was about uh who
controls the land who controls the laws
who controls the countries I believe
that Christianity in Islam are now
closer linked than ever before I believe
they're closer linked
um
now than they even were in the in the
day of the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him who who by the way encouraged
religious freedom and lived uh
completely peacefully with Christians I
believe today we are united by a common
enemy I think that the evil actions of
what's happening in the the world uh the
the degeneracy the the perversions the
the horrible things that we we see every
single day on our TV screens uh the
atrocities committed in the name of all
sorts of
um nonsense even you know uh
reproductive Freedom the the millions
and uh millions of of babies being
aborted every single day it's um
it's tragic and I believe that
Christianity and Islam now stand hand in
hand as brothers against the moral
degeneracy of the world so I don't see a
time in the future where there's going
to be
um any kind of beef between Muslims and
Christians and if you think there's
going to be any beef in my house between
me and my brother you are wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
foreign
so you're hearing this is Tristan Tate
brother of Andrew Tate yeah so we don't
hear much about him but people are
talking about Andrew Tate so we thought
we'd go ahead and give Tristan Tate an
invitation to Islam as we did for Andrew
Tate at one time and he accepted us so I
want to start off with this statement he
said is very interesting there are
people who will punch you in the face
for insulting and you think this is
everyone other than Muslim but he said
it's the Muslims no doubt yeah
there have been movies made mocking
Jesus peace and blessings be upon him
and the only protests that really came
out in the streets were for Muslims
it's very interesting if you see a lot
of the people that insult the prophet
Jesus peace and blessing in the west
atheists some people of different
backgrounds usually you don't see a
response from Christians you see a
response from many Muslim countries and
heads of states and stuff that say you
know we don't allow any profit to be
insulted we as Muslims love Moses peace
and blessings be upon him we love David
peace and blessings be upon him we love
Jesus peace and blessings be upon him we
love Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon them and we believe in all of the
prophets equally meaning we can't pick
and choose you know when you see a
common message that was brought by Moses
and before him Abraham and then Jesus
and Muhammad peace and blessings be upon
them Islam is the only religion that
gives an explanation why
for example many Jews even though they
find that Jesus peace and blessings upon
Him brought a very similar message to
Moses and Abraham they deny him
completely I was in Jerusalem or put and
I met many people who are rabbis and
Jews and I spoke to them and they used
very foul language about Jesus when I
when I asked him what do you think about
Jesus they used a word that starts with
a b and it is referring to a
illegitimate child one of them even
mocked he said Mary had a lover and she
was hiding it and this is a rabbi in
Israel I mean we take over the blast we
take that as an insult we take we defend
the honor of Mary peace and blessings be
upon her we believe she was a virgin we
believe it was a miraculous birth we
believe Jesus was a prophet sent by
Allah to guide the people of Israel to
back towards the monotheistic message
from when they had deviated into many
what we would consider today as Vida
Innovation the charging people trying to
make money off the 10 points on and so
on
when we speak to Christians they may
believe in Abraham and Moses and David
and Jesus peace and blessings upon them
but they're obviously worship prophets
like Jesus instead of following his true
message but they will deny the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
but we as Muslims can show why all of
them have the same message and why they
brought a similar theme to all their
Nations because we believe in the
prophet Muhammad the prophet Jesus the
prophet Moses peace and blessings be
upon all of them I want to go through
these quickly some of the points that he
made up and they kind of he's already
like given dawah he's not even Muslim
but he's clearing up many misconceptions
just by him speaking one of them he
feels at home like people often will
have this misconception in this land you
go there they'll chop your head off you
know all this stuff he's like I feel
comfortable here you know the the
propaganda that we see from the media is
very negative our brother in Islam Eddie
from the dean show is creating the
Center which is a Masjid and a tower
center which is going to help
non-muslims learn about Islam insha
Allah and the most beautiful thing about
this is that we can all be a part of
this we can all take part in earning
rewards from this simply by donating
whatever we can to make this a reality
which is beautiful let's do that all
right let's click this link let's donate
what we can and let's make this a
reality insha Allah
[Music]
foreign
and one of the things I was recently in
Qatar during the FIFA World Cup and I
think that was an excellent Allah reward
government and people of Qatar it was an
excellent example of clearing up many of
those misconceptions because sitting in
the west we hear this so This narrative
tells you that as if the Middle East is
just some kind of war zone and you go
there and some guy with like a sword is
going to jump out with a camel that's
you know ridiculous Hollywood stuff but
this is what we people think but in
Qatar they got to see that no Muslims
are first world people Muslims have a
very welcoming attitude people from
every different country in the world
that you can think of were there and
they were welcomed by the people they
were welcomed into the mosques many
people regular citizens nothing to do
with any Dao organization or any they
just came up to the streets and brought
their gawa their coffee and were passing
it out to the people and sweet just to
have that build building of bridges that
friendly conversation and it was
beautiful so I appreciate Chris
kind of clearing up these misconceptions
and letting people know that him living
in a majority Muslim country he feels
very comfortable even though he's a
Christian he talked about conversion or
coming to Islam this is not he doesn't
believe this is a a choice
I thought that was profound that was
very interesting uh and many people
don't realize what does it mean to
revert or to go back to the Natural
State of belief that children are born
on which we consider somebody becoming
Muslim as reverting back to their state
but he said something very interesting
that it's not a choice it's the same
thing as if you uh see that the water
the oceans are wet with water or the sky
is blue meaning when you realize that
there is a Creator and that Creator sent
this message this truth with his Prophet
then it's not about converting to
something it's about accepting reality
and that's a very profound point I mean
you know some people they want to live
out their desires and hopefully those
that are watching can kind of check
themselves you know kind of think about
their own life and their choices and
what they want to do they just want to
live out their desires so what do they
do they deny the the Creator or they may
believe in a Creator but they don't want
to follow the rules right so then
they're like well I believe in God but
I'm not a Muslim or you know because I
want to drink and there was a uh
somebody had done a reaction to one of
my videos and there was somebody in that
who had made that comment that I don't
call myself a Muslim because the
lifestyle that I'm living well so so
that's that's an interesting point that
because they want to go party your drink
or fornicate or whatever they want to
then deny the message and this is not
something you can do because when you
know there is a Creator and you know
that that Creator Creator you didn't
come from and nowhere you were you were
designed and fashioned and evolved by
the will of the creator
you have to accept that it's a truth
it's like saying the Sun is hot I mean
it's not a matter of opinion once you
realize the Sun is hot it's hot I mean
this is where heat comes from it's a
fact that there is a Creator as a fact
whether you like it or not whether you
want to deny it or not you can close
your eyes to it but it's a fact and many
people that want to deny it it's only
because they don't want to accept the
rules and regulations the creator has
set but it's not a choice once you know
that there's a Creator you know that
Creator knows better than you wants the
best for you knows what's best for you
so to accept that and then do your best
to follow the rules and regulations as
best you can but you can't deny there's
a Creator just because you don't want to
accept the rules and regulations to live
by
he talks about being given a book
miracles of the problem
what kind of Miracles do you think he's
going to see in his book I mean that's a
whole Topic in and of itself but are
they enough to convince any sincere
person that indeed Islam is from the
crater this is indeed a messenger or
from the creator of the heavens and the
Earth without a shadow of a doubt you
know I I taught a series on the life of
the Prophet peace and blessings be upon
him we call the Sierra and as I was
researching uh there are books like
Della and Naboo of albeit and others
that we went over to try to find uh
narrations about the life of the Prophet
peace be upon him and I found around 3
000 a Hadith about the different
Miracles the prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon it three thousand
narrations now some of those are about
the same Miracle but three thousand and
going through the historic documentation
first hand eyewitness accounts if we
just look at the miracle of the
splitting of the Moon and something I
think me and you've spoken about in the
past and we have a video about that's
particularly talks about the eyewitness
account scientific evidence historic
evidence non-muslim sources and all of
that if we just look at that by itself
it would be enough to believe in him as
a prophet peace and blessings be upon
him and if you believe in his
prophethood that is Islam believing in
the Quran that was revealed in what he
has told us that the message from the
Creator other than that there are many
many incidents through Wars through
times when water came out of his hands
where where people were healed like Ali
radian who had an ailment in his eye
that was healed at his hand and so many
others
now what's unique about the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him is that we
have first hand eyewitness accounts that
are verified with what we call the
Senate the chain of narrators who told
who who told who who told who until
Butch Big's books were they documented
in which you don't have for the earlier
prophets meaning if we talk about Moses
spitting the sea who's the eyewitness
account what was their names how good
was their memory who did they tell that
account to until it was written down we
don't have that information even Jesus
walking on water peace and blessings be
upon all the prophets
who was the eyewitness who did that
eyewitness physically tell it to who did
they physically tell it to we don't have
that chain so it's kind of a blind faith
issue but not with Islam with Islam we
can tell you for example spreading of
the Moon we have Abdullah
Malik who's in Medina we have other
sahaba that we can name you who they are
even the enemies of the Prophet peace be
upon and we can name you who they were
and who they told that they saw this
miracle even the politicism
they admitted to this miracle that chain
can be verified each narrator and how
good their memory is how was their moral
character who else heard this so this is
a very unique way to scientifically
prove these miracles truly amazing
amazing and like I said anybody who's
sincere Tristan Tate he looks into this
and he just puts this to the test the
Quran is the living Miracle along with
all these other Miracles that you're
talking about
there's no room left for doubt no doubt
for this thing Tristan if you're
watching this and the people watching
can share this video with him we want to
invite you you know alhamdulillah your
brother is a Muslim and um but you know
right now uh he's in jail Tristan as
well yeah both of them are in jail
inshallah we hope that Allah frees our
brother Andrew Tate and we hope that
Tristan takes this time in jail to
contemplate upon Islam and upon the
purpose of life and we invite you to
Islam and sneako inshallah we want to do
a live stream with you as well inshallah
I know sneak was close to Islam
alhamdulillah I saw he did a reaction to
one of my videos and I've definitely
wanted to reach out to him and others
that are watching we want to invite you
to the truth and like Tristan said in
this profound way that that when you
know that this is the truth it is just
just accepting the fact it's not
changing it's not something that you're
you're choosing to convert no you
realize Islam is the truth then it's
just accepting the truth what do you say
to a lot of Muslims you get some
pushback because you're even bringing up
their names and you know they have a lot
of things you know that they were
indulging in you know especially agitate
before Islam now he's come over to Islam
and uh from his good friend that I've
interviewed Tam Khan he's talking about
how he's going to be leaving a lot of
these things I know he openly came out
and he left alcohol I'm good involved
with some gambling he's his friend was
saying that he knows his arm he needs to
get out of it but now you deal with a
lot of people coming into Islam how long
those Transitions and how should Muslims
go ahead and you know to understand that
this is a person to Islam and how to
deal with this and because you have some
people with strong condemnations you
know what I mean and like this is uh you
know I saw an interesting tweet uh
somebody showed me a screenshot I don't
even know it was from uh some sister
said that if the Muslim Community
accepts and rotate as a Muslim I'm going
to leave Islam and I was shocked by this
because that's such a pathetic thing to
say uh if the worst criminal becomes a
Muslim we should accept them and hope
good for them and hope that they will
change their ways and be a support
network for them to change Islam is the
solution for people to get out of that
lifestyle if Andrew Tate lived a
lifestyle that was a criminal lifestyle
before Islam and he was involved in the
wars of sins well then Islam is a
solution how can you be accept how can
you be upset about him choosing the
solution and and if some of those bad
habits are not gone immediately it
doesn't mean that we we we reject the
brother you know and this is something
pathetic uh you know to be honest Eddie
I don't even pay attention to the haters
you know there's people out there that
they got nothing better to do but you
pick faults and make videos against you
and and just sit there they sit in their
mother's basement and and they don't
have a life and they just sit there and
watch and they just have this hatred why
is Andrew Tate being said why is you
know Eddie doing good why is othman
doing good and they just they have this
boiling hate let them burn in their hate
we don't care about them we keep moving
in a positive direction we follow the
Quran we followed What did the prophet
Allah tell us he told us about a man
that killed 99 people now I don't know
to be very honest with you I don't know
and rotates past I never heard the name
Andrew Tate until his interaction with
Islam because I'm busy and I got things
to do so to be honest when I heard about
undertale people started telling me
about him and things like this and
alhamdulillah at that time he was
already interested in Islam
um I had a conversation with snico so
you know we were having these before his
Islam
alhamdulillah when he accepted Islam uh
we saw a lot of brothers that were very
happy and we saw some haters kind of
talking about well you know he was
involved in this and that and I was
shocked because I look at the Hadith of
the man who killed 99 people now I don't
know what Andrew Tate has done in the
past but I really doubt he killed 99
people you know and this man killed 99
people he asked the the worshiper is
there a way for me to repent he said no
so he killed a hundred he killed him
made it a hundred right and then he went
to the person of knowledge he said can I
Repent he said yes but change your
environment leave the environment that
you're in go to the place of the
righteous and this man and I'm
summarizing he died on the way he never
even made it to the place but Allah made
the land shorter closer to the place of
the pious to forgive him
so if Andrew Tate was a horrible person
in the past alhamdulillah is Muslim so
he can leave those ills he can leave
those evils and as what we have seen and
Allah knows best that he is now living
in a majority Muslim country the United
Arab Emirates
um even though he travels but I believe
that's where he's based out of and
that's good he's moving away from places
of kofora and may Allah make it that he
surrounds himself with good Pious people
and he leaves that sinful lifestyle
altogether now to address those that say
oh well even now he has some
shortcomings which I don't know what he
has or not I'm not here to assume bad
about our brothers so if then is
something we don't do we don't assume
bad about somebody as a Muslim we have
done we expect good about our brother we
make excuses for our brother so even if
he has some shortcomings still that
doesn't mean we condemn the brother that
means we support the brother we give
advice to the brother so he can leave
those ills if we look at the Hadith she
said that when the Quran was revealed if
the first thing that was revealed were
all the rules and regulations nobody
were able to do it if the first thing
that was revealed was you can't make
Xena and you can't drink alcohol and you
have to pray and this and this and you
can't gamble people wouldn't have been
able to handle it so Allah revealed the
Quran in stages and Makkah it was all
building Iman very few rules in Makkah
it was all about building your faith you
know building your connection with Allah
recognize that there is only Allah not
worshiping anything else not allowing
there to be any polytheism and things to
build that beautiful toheed that belief
in the Oneness of Allah about the sifat
of Allah but the about the uh the
characteristics of Allah the beautiful
names of Allah the mercy of Allah now
when the people went to Medina they made
Hijra they moved now that they had that
level of Iman now the rules came right
so now if somebody becomes Muslim first
thing we hope for them that they will
build their faith and slowly slowly
leave everything bad if they can leave
everything bad in one night great but if
they can account it doesn't mean that we
just condemn them and Exile them and and
don't speak about no we make Dua for
them we supplicate for them we ask Allah
to guide them and we support them and we
help them and even if they fall back
into their sins we know Allah is the
most forgiving and we remind them to
always turn to Allah so we don't pay
attention to these haters we hope good
for our brother Andrew we hope that his
brother Tristan accepts Islam we hope
that sneako accepts Islam and we hope
that everybody everybody watching even
if they're not social influencers or
YouTubers or tick tockers or MMA famous
stars or any of that we hope you accept
Islam and everybody's Islam is equally
important to us and that's pretty much
believing in your in your heart and in
expressing with your limbs and then
living by the complete submission to the
creator of the heavens and earth and
that starts with that testimony of
ladies
and as we close this is what we're
inviting Andrew takes brother Andrew
Tate already accepted Islam I haven't
been very very related and happy that
his brother also when I was younger
brother and usually the younger brother
looks up to the older brother right or
giving him that invitation to come to
the submission and surrender of the
creator of the heavens and earth and
what does that entail like Christian
said it is just coming to grips with
reality
whether you believe in the Creator or
not the Creator created us whether you
believe in the Quran or not it's the
words of Allah
we want Tristan to take that step and
accept what he knows in his heart to be
true
so as his brother has done and as
millions of people do all the time
throughout the world alhamdulillah
um
belief in Islam starts in the heart
it's something that begins in the heart
where nobody can see it but you have it
and it's expressed on the tongue when
you say your testimony of faith when you
say
this is the testimony of Faith saying it
the Bible bear witness there is none
worthy of worship except Allah and I
bear witness that Muhammad is a servant
and messenger of Allah this is the
testimony of faith and then it is
expressed on the limbs meaning then your
body submits those actions of your faith
are in your daily prayers to the best of
your ability you're leaving the the
things that are forbidden that are Haram
and doing that which Allah has ordained
that which is father that is obligatory
and so on
and this is something that will
spiritually cleanse them it will benefit
them it will bring the peace in their
heart that people are missing it will
bring that discipline in their day that
people are missing it will bring that
healthy lifestyle that people are
missing it will give them that purpose
that people don't realize that they have
it will give them the best of what is
there in this world and will give them
Everlasting Paradise in the Hereafter
thank you very much pleasure again
you can't take it with you when you go
or you can't take this with you when you
go and you can't take this with you when
you go brothers and sisters we're all
going to depart from this life and all
of our material possessions to our money
will stay behind but your reoccurring
investment in the dean Center will
continue to grow even when you leave
this life so go ahead and make that
reoccurring investment in a Masjid Mega
Tower Center that will benefit you in
this life and in the next click the link
below donate right now may God Almighty
Allah reward all of you
cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedenshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you